hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
it's John Humphrey over here we're gonna
watch the official trailer number toes
for Marvel's The Punisher I wonder when
this is actually coming out on Netflix
knocked over last time maybe we will get
a real one this time maybe it comes out
tomorrow it comes out tonight before we
go into this we mentioned this in our
most recent upload but I want it to
remind you guys again please download
and follow us at this new app that were
partnered up with called stars
Stardust is this app that allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film
trailer or any TV show that's right
since we're probably not going to review
every single episode of Marvel's The
Punisher we thought we need to remind
you guys about it because well at least
definitely give you our quick thoughts
on every single episode after we're done
watching them so that way we can still
keep you up to date on our viewing
experience so we'll definitely do a
series of you for it yeah and make sure
to download and follow us first that way
they know we sent you guys and you know
if you don't follow us there's a bunch
of other youtubers that you guys love on
their late to the party Jon Roca Jared
oh my John Clark wolf pretty much
everyone a Collider at this point and
also if you guys follow us you might be
able to be featured in one of our
upcoming videos as well the video for
Blade Runner 2049 keep your ears out
we'll post the call you post some
reactions tag us and start us in those
posts and then we might just pick
I'm the only authority you'll need I
point you shoot did you kill the target
[Music]
oh we're doing was wrong you did what
you were supposed to do right now the
only person you're punishing is yourself
punished Frank Castle got something I
need to show
the video files that US military turns
over hit man Frankie
[Music]
better I think you know the bobwhite
case is the last witness
we can either clean this up or let them
take us down
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
Oh horrible car chase
[Music]
gerrant
[Music]
it's our tradition
[Music]
[Music]
the world needs to see the truth
[Music]
November 17th we have a date we can
prepare for this coming out the same day
that's justice Lee this is DC vs. Marvel
right here
they're not both playing in the theaters
I know one you could just watch at home
on a streaming server so you can watch
Justice League and then catch on the
punisher whenever you want but it is
kind of funny yeah two main competing
companies releasing two properties on
the same highly anticipated long-awaited
property it's gonna be a busy weekend
for us and then we'll go somewhere to
watch seeing just how many different
characters are wielding guns in this
trailer I can see why they did push the
trailer at new york comic con man yeah
that looks like a violent violent show
I'm so excited for it I can't wait to
see how bloody it gets I wouldn't say
that Marvel Netflix shows have this
consistency where every episode
progressively tends to get more and more
intense something tells me there might
be a rhythm to this show kind of like an
action movie as each episode goes the
pacing and rhythm and the intensity will
just keep amping up every single episode
you know a lot of times every episode of
the Marvel shows you know they can
fluctuate some episodes are more intense
than others I have a feeling this is
gonna be very rhythmic in escalator yeah
just a constant escalation going on see
I'm wondering how they're gonna balance
out the origins stuff with the
present-day stuff because it looks like
there's a fair amount of both Marvel's
trusts have done that pretty well Luke
Cage did it pretty well Jessica Jones
did it pretty well usually there's like
an episode or two dedicated to really
the origin stuff the first part of the
trailer all that military stuff and like
really diving into the past and the
assassination with his family like it
looks like it's a significant piece of
this you know or it might tie in to
whatever the presents yeah I might just
do it with flashbacks and I might do
kind of what the CW arrow show does
where like a few minutes every episode
is a flashback so that way it all comes
full circle by the Aniyah
or this might be one giant exposition
episode that micro character is not a
mining minor characters names Micro he's
not very small yeah he was the one
telling Frank you know like they're the
ones who turn you into a weapon and give
me that backstory looking into who Frank
Castle is why he became the way he is I
imagine that when their relationship
starts to form that's probably when
we'll get a lot more Frank castles
backstory yeah I mean an action sequence
that I got really excited for man
there's gonna be a lot of cool gunplay
imagine what the action sequence I got
me excited was the car chase that looked
like a full-on car chase sequence yeah
and to see how Marvel handles that yeah
with their TV shows you know it's
especially since the Punisher the
introduction of him came from the
daredevil show I'm hoping that like okay
we can see some really awesome movie
level quality gunfights
and also a car chase sequence because
the way it was directed and just a brief
images we got a look that looks like
movie quality car chase yeah I mean
you're right there in the in the
wreckage yeah you know and that looks
super into the camera smooth - I really
hope that this series ends you know the
final episode ends with him becoming a
priest so that when daredevil season 3
premieres it's just him and Matt
constantly I guess my last thought is
Karen page is gonna be reoccurring in
this series and the comic books for
daredevil Karen page is like one of his
like biggest i think it is his main love
interest oh dang kill me if I'm wrong
everybody yeah I'm thinking if Marvel
will kind of toy with that a little bit
you get hints of Karen and Frank
possibly being somewhat romantically
interested or some condition yeah yeah
they certainly have a connection with
each other I'm wondering if the show
more of The Punisher will toy with that
and maybe even have them kiss or
something you know play with fans Jacob
or Edward Oh Karen does seem like she
has a thing for troubled dudes who beat
lots of ass well the thing is Karen
needs to go to therapy so she can let
that stuff go so she's not drawn to men
who are probably very unhealthy for her
why are you drawn to like not just our
guys but like next level
yeah like going out in the city and
stopping pearl well guys November 17th
we got the date March will probably
watch Justice League on November 16 so
then we could just binge the punisher
all throughout the weekend and never
leave this apartment yeah you know not
enjoy the way shows I'm told simply plow
through them and ask for the next day
and then follow us in the star ghost app
so you can get our quick opinions on
every single one we'll definitely a
series review by the time it's done
anyway guys thanks for tuning in you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell - on Humphry on
twitter and instagram yeah